emmanuel macron sur les terres du député
benoît hamon pour l'un des derniers
meetings ses militants se sont réunis à
trappes en fin de semaine dernière une
ville comme travel est emblématique dans
notre projet parce que elle symbolise
justement tout tout ce dynamisme qu'on
retrouve au sein des populations qu'on
retrouve au sein de la société civile
mais qu'on ne ressent pas
quand on regarde les résultats
thématique de la soirée l'économie
sociale et solidaire une politique cher
à benoît hamon qui a porté une loi sur
le sujet loi promulguée le 31 juillet
valérie flâner star avait dit à la
mitterrand vous n'avez pas le monopole
du coeur benoît hamon n'a pas le
monopole de la ss est en fait dans le
rôle de porte parole à deux le ss je
suis a amené à aller dans tous les
territoires pour parler de ces
problématiques qui sont au coeur du
projet de des maillots la con dans la
salle des soutiens de benoît hamon sont
venus constater la mobilisation des
trappistes derrière emmanuel macron la
plupart des militants du mouvement en
marche présents ce soir là sont venus du
nord des yvelines je sais quel est
l'enjeu pour en marche pour conquérir
cette ville on sait bien qu'elle ait le
député de ce territoire
je ne rentrerai pas dans les détails
mais pour moi c'est un enjeu énorme de
marché dans cette ville il a un projet
qui est tourner également vers les
personnes qui habitent dans des
quartiers qui sont dits défavorisés
il a tout ce qu'il faut dans son
programme pour permettre à ces personnes
de se sortir de leur leur misère sociale
de le mieux les accompagner
donc il était important de venir sur le
terrain pour montrer l'attachement de
d'emmanuel macron à ces populations
dernière ligne droite pour les militants
yvelinois avant le premier tour de
l'élection présidentielle ce dimanche 23
avril